hi my name is harshat kalankri i
graduated in the year 2020. i'm
currently residing in hyderabad after
completing my engineering i was placed
into pune as a business analyst but that
didn't really work out for me coming
from the computer domain i wanted to
expertise something in it feed
that's when i realized that simply
learns full stack java development
course is one of the most prominent
comprehensive aspects
after completing my course in the span
of over two months i was given five
various opportunities from simply done
one of them was converted to me as a
software engineer in my com osi
one of the key reasons why i chose
simply learn over the others was its job
guarantee program
it helps students to get placed into
companies that is related to the course
they have chosen and simply learn it was
very engaging easy to understand the
topics the reason it was interesting is
because of the life projects the
self-learning videos constant support of
mentors
i'd use this opportunity to also thanks
pawan who helped me through all the
interview process guidance and other
opportunities that were coming in my way
this course not only helped me
professionally but also personally
it helped me understand the importance
and value of time management hard
working perseverance and efficiency this
course also was a great bone to my
family my parents were very elated to
see i'm finally doing something that
i've always strived for and i think that
makes everyone happy
the fsg was a game changer for me it
helped me understand the elements and
essence that i required for the job in
the industry standards it also helped me
rather than self-learning but open a
path through which i can learn more
understand more upskill and get better
professional opportunities for my future
keep learning and success is guaranteed